the latest infection data for england
has been released in england around 1 in
60 people have tested positive for
coronavirus this number is higher in
london northeast england yorkshire and
the humber with one in 45 people likely
to test positive in the northeast
infection rates are lower in the west
midlands with around 1 in 75 people
testing positive on average
well with us now is skies ashish joshi
who's in west london for us ashish break
down these figures for us what do you
make of all of this
well we knew which way the trend was
going simon and this is just
confirmation of that this is the week
ending december the third so it doesn't
take into account any of the um omicron
cases and the ons the office of national
statistics say as much it's too early to
see what sort of impact omicron might be
having that the numbers are very low at
the moment but all of the numbers in
england in northern ireland wales and
scotland they're all
going upwards and we saw that with the
the pattern over the last week we saw
that numbers were reaching 44 45 50 000
yesterday of number of infections and
these are the infections in re in in
residential homes so these are not in
care homes or hospitals but these are in
residential homes in um
community settings and these are people
who've tested positive on a pcr test we
know that the the rate the trend is
upwards at the moment
and this is a good way to remind people
that although we might have been
distracted a little weak over the past
week talking about omicron and
everything else that the numbers are
still high
luckily because of the the vaccine roll
out these these aren't being
transferred into hospitals but the
hospitals are busy anyway with their own
backlog but they're not dealing with a
surge in covert cases or
hospitalizations but it is a reminder
that we are still very much in a
pandemic still dealing with the delta
variants